now that's a snackity snack
[Music]
birthday feast presents snack after
school special
hey everyone i'm burger scholar george
moats welcoming you to a very special
episode of snacked i'm here with the
first few piece crew and back in the
kitchen i got sorry um
today me and the first free feast crew a
[ __ ] fifth tough hit
wow
that's actually harder than i thought
i'm back in the kitchen with the first
we feast crew making our favorite after
school snacks for a very good cause to
help raise money for our long time
charity partner common threads
that okay
common threads is an awesome
organization that provides healthy food
and cooking instruction for kids all
year round so what can you do hit that
donation button to help them reach their
goal so in the spirit of gearing up for
school i'm going to show you a very
popular moats household after school
snack no it's not a burger it's nachos
nachos who doesn't love nachos one of
the easiest things in the world to make
and to help me make some nachos how
about the person that i make them for
all the time
my daughter
ruby
hey
there she is she's not only my daughter
she's also behind the camera
some of the time on burger scholar
sessions
okay so how often do i make this ruby
like
maybe once a week do it's a week exactly
do you know the history of that nachos
who do you think invented nachos
i have no idea okay name nacho okay
but not only that 1943.
this is a very old recipe so i used to
make this ruby all the time after school
but now ruby's going to college this
year and guess what she comes home at 2
o'clock in the morning with her friends
and we make it dad always stays up to
make sure she's getting home okay and
then dad can i have nachos and you make
them and i make them great and my
friends love it exactly and the reason i
made them is because we always have the
stuff in the owl
we always have the stuff in the house
right that's the beauty of nachos is
that you always usually have this kind
of stuff in your house are you ready to
make nachos let's do this
so one layer of chips right
next we have to take some grate some
cheese
and of course a lot of cheese is good
okay
so you can put some cheese on there now
more chips on top of that it's almost
like a nacho sandwich here you got that
jalapenos go on here spaced up nicely
okay now next the beef i'll do this part
just sprinkle some beef on here
ground beef what comes to actually think
no hot sauce
hot sauce
so we put the hot sauce on before it
goes in the oven because it actually
gets into the beef and the cheese you'll
see it's like a party in the oven right
now so we also use i'm also using some
el yucateco chipotle this stuff is
actually very hot and smoked this is why
i'm not going on hot ones because this
is too hot for me
uh-oh
yeah
that's hot oh man it's hot
there we go now cheese on top of that
right more cheese i like them cheesy i
like them crispy
look at that
we're gonna put this beautiful toaster
oven it is hot
but it's only on broil you don't want to
bake your chips to turn into some kind
of like baked meal and keep an eye on it
this is going to cook fast
oh god okay see what's happened here
look at that oh yes
look at that in the first few piece
kitchen
making magic sorry
oh yes look at that
okay now people think do i use a knife
and a fork no kids you use your hands
you got little utensils right here right
now it's very clutch here we take the
sour cream
whoa i'm sorry about that well that's
what you do actually did i get you yeah
oh [ __ ] sorry about that you put it
right on the thing
ow okay and we dip into that we're
dipping in there that's it ready yeah
you first
[Music]
mmm you dip and that's it
[Music]
come on it's so good
the cheese underneath is melted that
cheese on top is crispy
that's
perfect nachos hmm
that was so good thanks for being
honored this was fun thanks for having
me
remember to hit that donate button take
it away nicole
hi everybody it's nicole russell host of
peace awards and today i'm going to make
you the best snacking snack ever english
muffin pizzas you ready when i was
growing up i was a latchkey kid so my
parents didn't order any pizza for me i
had to make pizza myself and this is
what i used to do the english muffin is
a perfect base for a little piece of
snack everyone talks about the pizza
bagel but no the english muffin is where
it's at look at these nooks and crannies
all in here and these are just perfect
pockets for your sauce we all remember
the nasty school pizza i couldn't stand
it so i would always come home and just
make my own little pizza out of these
english muffins and they were great much
better than what was at school
so first things first what we're gonna
do so we're gonna take this marinara i'm
gonna put some on here then we're gonna
get a little oregano for flavor
and then we're gonna put a little
mozzarella cheese
and this is a simple snackity snack
we're not getting crazy but
the chicken nuggets you know i used to
love these super nostalgic and today
we're going to use them to make our
chicken parm pizza i'm just going to cut
them up into small pieces
like so
however bite size pieces you would want
to do it and then some people don't like
a lot of sauce me personally i like a
little sauce
so we want to get a little sauce on top
of that then add your cheese
and then a little
garlic and this baby is ready to go in
the oven
pizza is fun and this is so much fun for
the kids
okay this is done it smells so good
already
i can't wait to try
come on
come on
look at that
you can put a little bit more garlic on
here and if you want to make it look
more like a chicken parm because you can
eat it just like this put a little sauce
on top right
um
that's delicious
and then
you just bite into it
[Applause]
now that's a snacky snack
all right well thanks again everyone
don't forget to hit that donation button
and alvin take it away
what's up everybody it's your boy alvin
kailan and this is my after school snack
that i make pondysol spam egg sandwich
it's mandatory to have these products in
a filipino household this is one of my
favorite things to eat growing up
this
is how you make an ultimate snack let's
get started we got pandesal which is
light airy it's a classic filipino bread
and we always have it if you go to a
filipino household and they don't have
this
by the dozens in their freezer
they're not filipino
get some butter
onto the griddle
that you're getting it toasted all the
way through
and then
we get the spam
right here
the secret to opening this is slamming
it onto the cutting board and it pops
right out
i like to cut them at a quarter inch
slice
we'll go with three for this sandwich
beautiful crisp go in and if you know me
you know
a lot of my sauces start off with
mayonnaise about two tablespoons and
then jufran banana ketchup one of my
favorite dipping sauces banana ketchup
is everything in in the filipino
household like we put banana ketchup in
our spaghetti sauce like it's it's wild
and we're gonna sauce the bottom then
we'll sauce the top our spam is ready
look at this
it's egg time
crack the egg on a flat surface
boom
hit it with a little bit of salt
i like to season it with my scallions at
this point so it gets stuck to the egg
you're gently rolling it over like that
and just like that
you have a beautiful fried egg
with scallions married into it got that
nice onion bite put it on top of the
spam
beautiful spam egg banana ketchup aioli
check it out
look at this
amazing
it's
dripping everywhere this is
the snack for the gods
[Music]
biting into that i'm seeing
ducktales i'm seeing rescue rangers i'm
seeing my childhood in one bite and that
honestly that is the greatest thing
about food is when food can transport
you back in time you did a great job if
you don't make this
you're missing out don't forget to hit
that donate button it's for a good cause
it's got some good snacks
let's go
hope you enjoyed the snacks you saw here
today maybe you were inspired to make
something after school don't forget to
donate please and i'll see you next time